Lightning strikes above the highest tower
of the imposing, medieval castle standing
atop the hill in front of you.
The surrounding landscape beneath the fortress
is a dark forest, just perfect for hiding
untold numbers of dangers.
You’re not exactly sure where you are, or
why you were brought here, but you never do.
It doesn’t matter though, you’ll figure
it all out in due time.
You always do.
The context of why you’re brought to the
places you need to be is never important.
In fact, you don’t pay it any mind at all.
All that matters is that you help the people
who need it the most.
Save them from the terror that seems to creep
around every corner.
No matter where you wind up, it’s always
a struggle.
These people seem bent on doing everything
in ways that seem to always put them in the
most danger.
The world seems to revel in that danger, sometimes
outsmarting you and coming up with new ways
to hurt and terrify those who you try to help.
But it doesn’t matter.
You’re a hero.
In fact, with how many new places and settings
you seem to instantaneously crop up in, you
seem to be the hero.
That’s always how you’ve been.
You hop from one location to the next, the
days bleeding into one another, never needing
rest.
You’re not even sure who you are, in a traditional
sense.
You don’t know your name, your appearance
is vague and fuzzy, your humanity itself is
even debatable, but you don’t care about
any of that.
Deep inside you, there’s a drive, a drive
to help others and save them from the cruelness
and horrors of the situations they find themselves
in.
You can never pin it down, but nothing ever
feels right.
In the places you crop up, things just seem
to work against these folks as much as they
can.
Cars don’t start while knife-brandishing
killers pursue them from the woods.
Undead zombies always seem to know where others
are hiding.
Ghosts and monsters know the exact ways to
terrify and scare their victims.
Ordinary, kind people always seem to find
themselves in the most unexplainable, unfortunate
situations, caught up in tales of the supernatural,
of the arcane, and of absolute terror.
It’s like the universe is working against
them, putting them in these situations on
purpose.
Almost for entertainment purposes.
But you’re smarter than that, and you have
been for as long as you’ve been doing this,
which is a very, very long time.
Jumping from one location to the next, contending
with paranormal activity and supernatural
foes, saving would-be victims from their clutches.
You understand that this is your purpose.
You understand that you are a hero.
And that’s all you need to know.
You’ve picked up quite the skillset and
contextual savviness over the thousands of
times you’ve done this.
“Don’t go down that alleyway”, “Don’t
split up from a group”, and “Don’t leave
the house” are some of the more common platitudes
you have to tell the people you meet on your
journeys.
They seem obvious enough, but most of the
time, they don’t listen.
They go on vacation, against your wishes,
and then they find themselves in a haunted
hotel room.
They send their kids to a summer camp, only
to find that it’s being stalked by a brutalizing
slasher.
They move into a house with a history of being
haunted, and are somehow surprised when the
spirits don’t take kindly to their new guests.
To you, it all seems so obvious.
You’ve seen it all before that it’s predictable.
But for others, they have a serious difficulty
understanding that their lives are in imminent
danger.
For some reason, it’s like they’re predisposed
to doing the exact opposite of what you tell
them to do.
But it’s no matter.
Whatever they wind up doing, you’ll be there
to stop the horrific paranormal threats that
continuously endanger their lives.
After all, you’re the hero.
And so, you set off, moving towards the castle
in the distance.
You’re not sure of what you’re supposed
to do yet, but you’ll figure it out.
After a half hour of trekking in the dark,
misty woods, you come across a broken down,
old school car , stuck in a massive ditch.
Inside is a young couple, dressed in older
clothing.
They seem to be elated at your arrival, thanking
you before you’ve even done anything.
You ask them what happened, and they explain
that while driving, they got lost, and somehow
found themselves in this forest.
The fog was so thick, the man explained, that
he lost control of the vehicle entirely, and
found himself in a ditch.
You scratch your chin.
Like most situations you come across, you’ve
seen it before.
A young couple forced to take refuge in a
dangerous location after their vehicle broke
down.
And if you were a betting man, you’d wager
everything you own that the dangerous location
in question is none other than that creepy
castle on the hilltop.
You assist the couple, and try to help them
push the car out of the ditch.
You ask what their plan is, and of course,
they tell you that they’re planning on seeing
if they can spend the night in the castle.
You shake your head, wanting to tell them
it’s a bad idea, but if you come out of
the gate with a warning, it’s going to raise
questions.
No, your day-saving has to be as natural as
possible.
At least, when you can help it.
With some effort, you manage to free the car
from the ditch, setting it on the dirt road
once more.
The couple thanks you, but just as they try
to start the car again, a loud spark from
underneath the hood makes a loud pop in the
silent night air.
Of course.
The universe is doing everything it can to
get this helpless couple into that castle.
After some deliberation, you decide to hold
off on telling them to stay away from the
castle.
No reasonable person is going to want to stay
the night in an unfamiliar forest, and given
the time period you’ve found yourself in,
it’s not like you can call for help.
Besides, if you stay out here any longer and
delay going into the castle, who knows what
else the universe will throw at you.
Maybe you’ll be attacked by wolves, or crushed
under a conveniently falling tree.
The castle might be their best option for
short-term safety, but it’s almost certainly
packed with dangers of its own design.
You tell the couple that you’ll watch their
car, and that you’ll follow them shortly.
Maybe you can fix it, or figure out what’s
wrong.
In your travels, you’ve picked up some rudimentary
automobile knowledge.
Now, it’s time to put it to the test.
After a cautious goodbye, you watch the two
walk the steep hill to the imposing stone
castle, and knock on the large, wooden doors
with a timid push of the metal gargoyle door-knocker.
Now that they’re gone, you can work your
magic.
You wait until you see the couple greeted
by a woman with black hair and a red dress,
who welcomes them into the foyer with a concerningly
devilish laugh.
They’re all so gullible, you think to yourself,
but it doesn’t matter.
You have a job to do.
Throughout the night, you scope out the castle.
Sneaking around the outside, peering in windows
and traversing hidden passageways.
You’re pretty sure you’re unseen the whole
time, even by the numerous guard dogs and
strange, giant bat creatures that patrol the
premise.
Funny how that works.
When you want to be perceived, you have no
difficulty being noticed, but when you want
to be hidden, it’s like no one can notice
you.
While the universe may work against you in
so many ways, it’s also blessed you with
a variety of benefits and lucky breaks.
After all, you are the hero of this story,
and of every story you find yourself within.
You’ve determined, through your impeccably
stealthy sneaking skills, that this castle
belongs to none other than the Vampire Countess
Lady Brunhild Haas, an immortal creature who
feasts on the blood of humans and lives out
her days in a creepy, cob-web infested castle.
A by-the-books vampire, through and through.
You’ve contended with so many of them at
this point, they’re trivial.
Heck, you’ve saved hundreds of people from
the infamous Count Dracula, the deadliest
and most famous vampire of them all, multiple
times across multiple worlds by now.
You know all the tricks.
A stake through the heart, a silver bullet,
sunlight, garlic, fire, holy water.
Now that you think about it, vampire’s are
pretty vulnerable creatures, and if it weren’t
for their deceptive nature, quick thinking,
magical powers, and hyper-fast reflexes, it’d
be hard for anyone to find them scary.
Now understanding your target, it’s time
to play your part as the hero, vanquish this
monster, and save that couple.
Just as the Countess is planning to sneak
into the guest bedroom, where the couple is
sleeping, and sink her fangs into their necks,
you leap from the shadows with a wooden stake
you found inside the castle’s catacombs,
and hit her in the head with as much force
as possible.
It’s not enough, and the Countess lunges
forward, screeching.
The couple jolts awake, just in time to witness
the Countess and you duking it out in the
guest bedroom.
Seeing a vulnerable spot, the countess transforms
into a bat and flies toward the girl to attack,
but the Countess got greedy, because unfortunately
for her, she couldn’t predict that she was
within throwing distance of the stake you
picked up.
You hurl it forward, precision striking the
transformed countess right in the wing.
Injured, she changes back into her human form,
giving you enough time to pull the stake from
what was her wing and is now her bloody arm,
and drive it straight through her heart and
seal her fate forever.
It's not pretty, and you’re now covered
in vampire blood, but you got the job done.
The couple is shocked, but they both saw it
with their own eyes.
The countess was a vampire, she transformed
into a bat, and they need to get out of there.
You guide them through the castle, narrowly
avoiding the locations of all the guarding
creatures, and into a room containing the
countess’s horse-drawn carriage.
You set them off on their way just as the
sun rises, and remind them to not forget the
luggage in the back of their car that’s
still in the woods.
You feel a sense of satisfaction, as you always
do after your quests.
But as soon as that feeling washes over you,
you’re whisked away to a different location.
But this time, something is different.
You blink, and you wind up in what appears
to be a facility.
You’ve been to some place similar before,
but nothing like this.
It’s massive, filled with dozens upon dozens
of people rushing from hallway to hallway.
And in those hallways are doors, oh, so many
doors.
You scratch your head, but the confusion disappears
as you grab a young man in an orange jumpsuit
by the shoulders and inform him that he’s
about to be terminated due to misconduct in
a research environment.
You’re not even sure what that means, but
the words come out of you like they’re preordained.
It felt like the right thing to say, and you’re
not exactly wrong.
The man pushes your hand away, swearing at
you before moving forward, presumably to his
death.
Four armed guards approach you from the distance,
and before you know it, you’re taken to
a room with a two way glass, a microphone,
and a strange device strapped around your
neck, called by one of the labcoats as a “Scranton
Reality Anchor”, whatever that means.
They’ve given you a name.
SCP-2786.
And from what you can glean, they know quite
a bit about you.
A suited individual sits down across the two-way
glass and begins asking you questions.
You don’t have time for this, you have business
elsewhere.
You explain to the Agent, as he calls himself,
that you’re a hero, who goes from place
to place, wherever you’re called upon.
Those in distress, those suffering, you’re
their champion.
The agent asks why they found you inside horror
movies and books, and you’re taken back.
Books?
Movies?
What is he talking about?
You explain that your work is very real, and
that before the incident with the vampire,
you just finished dispatching of a hockey-mask
wearing slasher at Camp Crystal Lake and saving
a group of teenagers.
It was easy work for you, of course.
He was just one guy, and those kids ignored
all of the obvious warning signs.
The agent confirms that he saw you do that,
and you’re even more confused.
He was there?
The agent catches himself, and explains that
while he wasn’t exactly there, he watched
it play out in the movie.
He tries to explain that all of your adventures
are taking place in fictional locations.
Movies, books.
You, SCP-2786, enter these mediums through
mysterious, unknown means, and alter their
plots entirely.
Copies of films and books that you enter are
changed, and the characters always manage
to escape the horror of the film due to your
assistance.
You alter stories early, change them entirely.
Movies?
Books?
This is not only ridiculous, but it’s also
getting on your nerves.
The agent is wasting your time, and you have
to go save those guys in the orange jumpsuits
from being terminated or reassigned, or whatever
it is!
You stand up, and the anchor device somehow
turns itself off and detaches from your neck.
You phase through the wall on your left, unsure
exactly of how you did it, but it felt natural.
Maybe that’s how this world works.
Certain people can do things like this, and
these guys are trying to contain them.
Like a government organization, or the Men
in Black.
Your genre-savviness pays off yet again.
Whatever this SCP Foundation is, you’ve
read them like an open book, and now that
you understand the situation, you can do what
you were sent here to do.
You hear the sound of an alarm in the distance,
but you can’t be stopped.
Over the next few hours, you break into multiple
containment cells, freeing orange jumpsuits,
or D-Class Personnel, as they’re called
by the Foundation, as well as several other
kind, regular people who just happen to have
anomalous abilities contained within the site.
These Foundation types disgust you.
Thinking they can lock up human lives without
regard for their rights or dignity, studying
them.
You bet that they want to study you too, but
they’re not going to.
As soon as you feel your work is done, you’re
whisked away to another location, away from
the strange Foundation facility and into an
ordinary American city, where you assist a
cast of characters in narrowly avoiding the
traps and sinister games of a killer puppet
who wants to murder them.
But after getting the job done this time,
you’re not taken anywhere new.
You’re in the same location, over and over
again.
On a loop.
After the 48th time saving these characters,
you start to consider what the agent had told
you.
You enter films, books, horror stories.
You’re… fictional.
Well, meta-fictional.
You exist inside the work and out of it.
The prospects of this are strange and new,
but if they’re true, it might explain why
you’ve never felt like the people you save.
Like you always felt like you were in a story,
that you were the only ‘real’ person there.
If everyone else is just a character, what
does that make you?
Alone?
Entirely?
If you’re inside a movie right now, can
someone be looping it, playing back the DVD
over and over again to keep you trapped there?
Is it the Foundation?
Is this how the Foundation is going to contain
you?
No, you tell yourself.
You are not going to be contained.
Another 30 loops of the same, monotonous ordeal.
But then, you’re transported somewhere new.
You laugh to yourself, having somehow escaped
the trap planted by the Foundation.
Before you know it, you’ll be off to a new
story, and you can continue doing what you
do best.
But as the world fades out around you, it
doesn’t seem to come back.
You seem to be stuck in a sea of white, and
black, and red.
Those same colors, over and over, extending
on forever.
You walk for what seems to be hours, and as
you do, surroundings begin to form around
you.
A concrete wall.
A concrete floor.
A bed.
A door, leading to another endless sea of
white, red, and black.
And on the floor, a logo.
A circle within a circle, with three arrows
pointing inwards.
For the first time in your life, you’re
unsure of what you should be doing.
That logo, it’s the logo of the SCP Foundation,
and you look like you’re inside a containment
cell.
No.
You pound against the wall, collapsing it
and allowing the sea of white swallow you
whole.
More logos.
More empty brackets.
A file.
You’re inside a file.
No, a cell of your own design.
You’re creating the containment cell.
Your own brain, however it works, is generating
a narrative.
The narrative of you being contained by the
SCP Foundation.
A horror story, and that’s exactly what
the Foundation used to trap you.
You’re not sure where you are, nor can you
feel your body or even your sense of self.
All that you know is that you’re trapped.
You’ve been whisked away to a new story
alright, your story, and it seems to be harder
and harder to escape from.
But then, the cell around you collapsed once
more, and you found yourself in a familiar
setting.
A medieval castle, being urged by a queen
to slay a great evil.
You managed to escape!
You don’t know how you did it, but you’re
back to your old life, jumping from story
to story.
You know all the beats, all the cliches, and
all of the right things to do.
And for the next few hours, you do them, slaying
the great beast and stealing his divine amulet
to bring back to the kingdom.
But after the fact, it felt hollow.
It didn’t feel real.
Not like the other times.
You weren’t sure how a location could tell
a lie, but this one felt as if its truth were
paper-thin.
Was someone pulling the strings and making
this world a lie for them?
Like trickery, or an illusion.
And suddenly, just as you begin to suspect
this narrative to be another means of containment
generated by the Foundation, everything goes
back to that white containment cell.
They can’t keep you here.
You repeat it over and over, shouting it into
the distance.
You just want to go home, you beg.
They can’t control you.
You’re the hero of this story.
If you’re fictional, you’re a good character!
You did everything right!
You don’t understand, this is YOUR story,
and it will always be your story.
The Foundation is just another one of the
countless villains you’ve fought.
Those self-rightous murderers, you will surpass
them!
You shout into the void of television static
and endless torment for what seems like decades.
And when you tire of your yelling, you realize
one thing.
This is eternal.
Now go check out “SCP-1230 - A Hero Is Born”
and “SCP-423 - Self-Inserting Character”
for more plot-twisters and story-hoppers from
SCP Explained!